all right six one seven eight three zero
4750 we are taking phone calls let's go
to our next caller who I think is called
I don't even know what the area code I
think this is an international number is
that right yes that's right I'm from
Vienna Austria in Europe great whenever
you're going today I have a question I'm
watching your show nearly every day it's
pretty good to learn English my question
is when you're talking about the
president doesn't care which one you're
always calling him the leader of the
free world my question is easy and what
does this mean exactly yeah okay so to
to party a future and in in Europe we
have free health care we have our
freedoms we have free public schools we
have three universities and all these
kind and what the freedom means in
America yeah is it for black people do
they have freedom right well there's an
Oklahoma let's not Sully it for this
down the world okay when you first of
all when you say you have those things
for free I mean you're paying for them
through taxes in Europe right so they're
not free you're just paying for them in
a different way yeah of course
good okay so the term leader of the free
world dates back many decades and it's
it's a colloquial term meant to mean the
sort of most powerful leader of a
Western non communist nation right this
is I'm sort of giving you the history of
the term it's not a literal term it's
it's it's a term that has a lot of
historical meaning I've not actually
been saying that Donald Trump is the
leader of the free world in fact I've
made the case that with the election of
Donald Trump to the United States and
the laughingstock that he represents
that really you could make the case that
German Chancellor Angela Merkel would
now be the so-called leader of the free
world but I want to just be super clear
again since English isn't your first
language it's not a literal title right
we're talking about an idea when we talk
about the leader of the free world I
know it's no title but it's very
interesting because for me it would it
would sound more correct to call him the
leader of one of
most powerful countries in the world
right then the leader of the free world
it's almost funny when you hear that all
the time no it's over for all presidents
whatever they have done whatever they do
yeah call them the leader of the free
world it's a little bit confusing in
Europe to hear yes no I believe me I'm
in the United States and I'm confused by
it as well very very good topic I really
appreciate the call
your English is is doing great I don't
know how long you've been learning
English but it's it's excellent and I
really really appreciate the call thanks
a lot
goodbye all right thank you so much
apparently Pat a little bit of a delay
there because the tubes over to Europe
must not be as wide as the internet
tubes that we have here in the United
States I would imagine that's the case
yeah